[Music]
now because on the one hand the ethical
order essentially consists in this
immediate firmness of decision and for
that reason there is for consciousness
essentially only one law well on the
other hand the ethical powers are real
and effective in the self of
consciousness these powers acquire the
significance of excluding and opposing
one another in self-consciousness they
explicitly exist explicitly whereas in
the ethical order they are only implicit
the ethical consciousness because it is
decisively for one of the two powers is
essentially character it does not accept
that both in the same essential nature
for this reason the opposition between
them appears is an unfortunate collision
of duty merely with the reality which
possesses no rights of its own the
ethical consciousness is croisé
self-consciousness in this opposition
and as such it at once proceeds to force
into subjection to the law which it
accepts the reality which is opposed to
it or else to out with it since it sees
right only on one side and wrong on the
other that consciousness which belongs
to the divine law sees in the other side
only the violence of human Caprice
well that which holds to human law
season the other only the self will and
disobedient to the individual who
insists on being his own authority for
the commands of government have a
universal public meaning open to the
light of day the will of the other law
however is locked up in the darkness of
another regions and its outer existence
manifests as the will of an isolated
individual which is contradicting the
first is a wanton outrage
here in paragraph 466 now in this
section we're going to see emerge for
the first time the the conflict between
these two ethical powers the law of the
family and the divine on the one hand
which is corresponding to a kind of
hiddenness Hegel has also aligned this
with the feminine and on the other side
the human law the law of the government
the community that which is manifest and
open here he he's arranging them in the
conflict that they're going to now now
engage in and notice that what's
happening here he tells us is a kind of
mind set on the side of consciousness
that lines up on one side with one law
or one power against another and there
is a hint here that there's something
else going on on the part of other self
consciousnesses but the ones that matter
the most are splitting themselves onto
one field or another taking a side you
could say so he tells us that this this
arises because this ethical
consciousness is marked by a kind of
firmness a kind of resoluteness of
decision so it tells us that because of
this there is for consciousness
essentially only one law and in the past
paragraphs what we've seen is the
recognition of multiple laws two laws at
the very least and there was a kind of
not quite reciprocity but at least
grudging acknowledgement of each sides
somewhat legitimate demands or
requirements here each of the ethical
consciousness is saying no we are the
only law we are the only norm that
matters so he says on the other hand the
ethical powers are both real and
effective in the self of consciousness
but these powers
acquire the significance of excluding
and opposing each other so he talks
about them as a you know pushing each
other out and as being set in opposition
with each other so this is a really key
idea you know and Gagan gazettes here he
tells us that what is happening is that
they're acquiring significance they're
acquiring meaning by doing that and it
tells us that they exist explicitly in
self-consciousness so what we have here
is that on the one hand other people can
look at this and see while there are
both of these but insofar as somebody is
acting and we saw how important the act
of pot is going to be here in fully
committing insofar as somebody is fully
committed to either the human law or the
divine law they literally become unable
to see the other law or power as
something ethical the ethical gets
subsumed entirely onto their side so he
tells us that the ethical consciousness
is decisively for one of the two powers
and here he says that it's essentially
character this is something that will be
followed out a bit more in later
sections and in later paragraphs he
tells us that what does that mean here
it does not accept that both both powers
both laws both individuals representing
them have the same essential nature so
what kind of nature does the other law
have you notice there's kind of a
veiling here but I'm representing on the
chalkboard with this dotted line he says
for this reason the opposition between
them between the two ethical powers
embodying themselves in particular
individuals in self-consciousness for
this reason it does not have the the you
know the nature of two powers confront
each other maybe divvying up their turf
or grudgingly as I put acknowledging
each other's legitimacy no the other is
seen as illegitimate and there's
different modalities in which this will
take place as Hegel tells us so he says
it appears as an unfortunate collision
of what of duty duty on the side of the
ethical duty on the side of the one who
has identified him or herself with what
has value vit leak-tight right a
collision of duty with a reality of your
Cleese kite an actuality is another way
we could put it which is without right
is how Miller is translating here but we
might just as well say without any right
without any legitimacy on its side
correct laws right lacking in fact
lacking in rightness lacking in
rectitude if we want to take a cognate
so how does this play itself out he
tells us the ethical consciousness as
self-consciousness is in this opposition
and because of this it at once proceeds
to force into subjection to the law
which it accepts that is the power that
it identifies with whether that's a
human law or the divine law it tries to
force into subjection the other he tells
us that that it it forces it into
subjection the reality which is opposed
to it or it takes another alternative
path if it is unable to carry out this
process of forcing it and it tries to
out win it so by force or by fraud it is
going to get its way why is it trying to
get its way because it's way is in its
view the right way it's so obsessed with
what it actually is right on its side
what what is legitimate and what it's
its side portrays or requires that it
ends up losing from its own view the
actual legitimacy of the other side and
it treats it as something that merely
resisted that merely gets in the way
that merely tries to subvert itself in
its own manner and so he tells us that
since it sees right only on one side
namely its side and wrong on the other
that consciousness which belongs to the
divine law what does it see this is the
divine law and the family it sees in the
human law only the violence of human
Caprice the violence of human
arbitrariness it sees the government it
sees that person over there making rules
that seem to contravene God law or the
divine law or what the family requires
is why why does that guy get to make the
rules who who elected him King well
maybe he is elected king or something
like that
but so what right and on the other side
if we flip this around and now it's the
human law that is the ethical power that
we're talking about Hegel tells us that
the human laws to using the other only
the self will the stubbornness and the
disobedience of the individual who
insist on being his own authority the
irony here is that both of them within
their limited spheres are actually right
are actually enacting the ethical are
standing up for and speaking for a part
of what say justice demands but they're
unable to see that the other has any
legitimacy any you know right on their
side and they thereby also you know as
we said here they exclude that and they
cast that all as being on their own
positions so Hegel goes on and he tells
us
you know there's a there's an imbalance
here the commands of the government have
a universal public meaning open to the
light of date but the will of the other
law is locked up in the darkness of the
nether regions and in its outer
existence manifest as the will of an
isolated individual which is
contradicting the first is a wanton
outrage and who does he have in mind
here this is we're getting closer and
closer and closer to this being crayon
and Antigone in the play by Sophocles if
you haven't read that you want to go and
check it out because Hegel has this very
clearly in mind but what we've got here
are two different ethical powers that
now we've sketched out quite
sufficiently the human law and the
divine law embodied in the action of
individuals unable to come to terms with
each other except as something perverse
something wrong confronting them
in this way there arises in
consciousness the antithesis of the
known and the unknown
just as in substance there was an
antithesis of the conscious and the
unconscious and the absolute right of
ethical self-consciousness comes into
conflict with the divine right of
essential being for self consciousness
law consciousness the world of objective
reality and such as an essential being
but according to its substance it is the
unity of itself and this opposite an
ethical self consciousness is the
consciousness of that substance
therefore the object in its opposition
of the subject has lost entirely the
significance of having an essential
being of its own just as those spheres
in which it is only a thing as long
since vanished so to have those spheres
in which consciousness gives a fixed
existence to something from out of
itself and converts an isolated moment
into essence against such one-sidedness
the actual world has a power of its own
it stands leagued with truth against
consciousness and itself shows the
latter what truth is the ethical
consciousness however has drunk from the
cup of substance and has forgotten all
the one-sidedness of being for self of
its ends and peculiar notions and hands
therefore at the same time drowned in
the Stygian water all essentiality of
its own and all independence of the
objective actual world it's absolute
right is therefore that when it acts in
accordance with ethical law it shall
find in this actualization nothing else
but the fulfillment of this law itself
and the deed shall manifest only ethical
action what is ethical being at once
absolute essence and absolute power
cannot suffer any perversion of its
content if it were only absolute essence
without power it could suffer perversion
by the individuality that this as an
ethical consciousness when it gave up
its one-sided being for self renounce
its right to pervert the content just as
conversely mere power would be perverted
by essence if it were in one-sided being
for self on account of this unity the
individuality is the
your forma substance which is the
content and the action is the transition
from thought to actuality merely as the
movement of an insubstantial antithesis
whose moments have no particular
distinctive content and no essentiality
of their own consequently the absolute
right of the ethical consciousness is
that the D the shape in which it
actualizes itself shall be nothing else
but what it knows
Hegel begins paragraph 467 by telling us
that now we get to see arising two
different antitheses or Gagan that's
right Gagan is optimum it would be with
a plural there he talks about them each
and the singular and he contrasted them
against each other so you might say
there's a kind of opposition of
antithesis to antithesis here and there
there being also put into a kind of
analogy with each other the question you
want to think about is well what is he
actually doing with this in the rest of
the explanation that follows so the
first that he talks about is the known
versus the unknown he says this arises
in consciousness right the antithesis of
the known the Gov Wilson and the Nick
give Austin the not the not known or the
if we want to be very clever here the
knowing of what is not the knowing of
what isn't that's on the site of
consciousness and then he tells us that
in substance there was an antithesis of
the conscious and the unconscious the
Boston that the thing that is capable of
being conscious that that has
consciousness and the before slows and
that which is lacking consciousness so
unconscious here is not you know
Woodinville Boston or Nick in a Boston
but for most lows and it's lacking in
conscious when something's going to be
brought into consciousness gradually
through this so he told us that we have
these two different antipathies and then
he so the absolute right of ethical self
consciousness comes into conflict with
the divine right of essential being why
so he tells us for self consciousness
qua consciousness the world of objective
reality as such has an essential being
now notice what we've got set up here
we're reinventions
we have developed long ago in the
consciousness and self-consciousness
section so self-consciousness is not
only you know for itself and
self-conscious and reflexive and all
this other nice stuff but it is also
consciousness of a world of objective
reality and here you know Gagan stanley
kuvira kite a world of actuality that
presents itself as in the mode of
objects you could say Gagan gegen
stanley cahier i present itself by it by
giving itself to us what if we're
talking about phenomenology as things
that are different than us that are
other that we can take in and be
conscious of here then Hegel says ok so
that's part of the picture but now we
can consider the ethical agent the
individual human being who is acting
here in terms of substance not just
self-consciousness which seems to be
kind of a rather ephemeral thing but
actually being a person who is rooted in
doing what they think is right and
that's a different perspective on things
so he tells us according to its
substance it what is it
self-consciousness is the unity of
itself and its opposite what is the
opposite in this case the world of
objective reality so you know this is a
very important side of
self-consciousness the world you know if
it's going to be a world of objective
reality he has to have kind of a
subsistence of its own and yet on the
other hand it is for self consciousness
it is for the consciousness that can say
this is my world and now when we're
talking about ethical action we're going
beyond what was going on in the
consciousness section you know from
sense certainty all the way to force in
the understanding and even what was
going on in the self consciousness
section where it was another
self-consciousness that it was dealing
with now we're talking about a world of
objective reality that is a social
cultural world that it is dealing with
so he said that therefore the object
it's
ah position of the subject loses
entirely the significance of having an
essential being of its own it is for
self consciousness and then he says just
as those fears in which it is only a
thing have long since vanished so to
have those fears in which consciousness
gives a fixed existence to something
from out of itself and converts an
isolated moment into essence into two
what matters right now consciousness or
self-consciousness as ethical
consciousness it has that it doesn't
have to try to manufacture it out of
itself as we saw in the previous stages
and reason and even implicitly in what
was going on in the self consciousness
section now it has an ethical duty you
know as Italy conflict as we could say
and it has to follow that Hegel presents
this as being a movement of absolute
commitment that is going to come with
some implications or we might say some
outcomes that that necessarily follow
from that so he says against such
one-sidedness the actual world has a
power of its own so what is the
one-sidedness here self consciousness
trying to say well the world is just for
me and the world resistant and says no
no no you see this isn't all about you
let's not lapse into something like a
solipsism you know punches you in the
nose and says look things are the way
they are you better adjust yourself to
them not expect the world simply to
adjust itself to what you want it to be
in the case of the ethical
self-consciousness though he says that
there's something going in that's quite
different he says you know the in the
other case the world has a power of its
own assume lead with truth against
consciousness and it's all shows the
latter what truth is because because
self consciousness thinks it has the
truth and the world says no no here's
what the truth is but ethical
consciousness he says has drunk from the
cup of substance now that's a very
interesting way to
isn't it it is dreamt from not dreamt it
has drunk from the cup of club stamp it
is it is understood its own
substantiality and he compares this to
the river of LIF a which is
forgetfulness which is the the river
that if you drink from you forget
everything before that other than
perhaps your character who it is that
you are at the core so what is
self-consciousness forgotten it has
forgotten the the legitimacy of
everything other than the demands of the
ethical upon it in its own particular
mode as either what the divine law tells
it or what the human law tells it so he
goes on he says the ethical
consciousness is drunk from this cup and
has forgotten all the one-sidedness of
being for self of its own ends and
peculiar notions the things that are
distinctive to that individual its
stripping it away it's becoming
universal or at least an a universal
that is going to resist and stand up
against another universal and not even
counted as a universal so he says it is
it is a therefore at the same time
drowned in this Stygian water all
essentiality
of its own and all independence of the
objective actual world now remember that
this is not just a world of objects like
you know books and clothing and
chalkboards this is an objective actual
world of other persons and of other
ethical norms besides just the the ones
that this person is self consciousness
this individual is operating according
to and attempting to impose so they've
forgotten that this other side possesses
some reality and so the validity of its
own he goes on and he says if the
absolute right is therefore that when it
acts in accordance with ethical law it
shall find in this actualization
nothing else but the fulfillment of this
law itself and the deed shall manifest
only ethical action what is Hegel saying
there when somebody really is
single-minded we or we might even say
not just single-minded but rather of one
heart or has a unified will in terms of
what the duty that they're trying to
enact to follow in relation to the rest
of the world is motivated by the the
ethical demands of either the divine law
or the human law when they have that
single myth of purpose of intention
something happens something transforms
it we can look at it from the outside
and say that person is crazy
they're not taking into account all the
other factors in the situation and we're
right in in a sense to say that but if
we think that's only what's going on
we're actually missing out on something
that Hegel thinks is absolutely
essential here so let's go on and see
what else he says he says what is
ethical being at once absolute essence
and absolute power this is really key
he's going to stress absolute essence
and absolute power cannot suffer any
perversion of its content now he says if
you had one without the other
then you can have that if it were only
absolute essence without power it could
suffer perversion by the individuality
the individuality could be using the
ethical as let's say a cover or a mask
for satisfying its own desires or for
whatever corruption it wants to bring
into the system we see this sort of
thing all the time
Hegel by the way is not denying that
this is often the case with people
invoking the ethical but for the person
who truly is committed and who commits
him or herself wholeheartedly who throws
all of him or
all into the balance and says let the
chips fall where they are I'm going to
do what I know to be right or what I
hopefully not just feel but but think to
be right from a Hegelian perspective
because remember feeling is not a great
guide right compared to thought for that
person
there is no perversion there is no
corruption there is no going astray
there is no subverting the ethical into
something that is lesser than it instead
the ethical inhabits the person and
guides an orient them to justify them we
might even say so he goes on and he says
this is an ethical consciousness when it
gave up it's one-sided being for self it
renounced its right to pervert the
content if you're really committed then
you don't get to take it back and say oh
you know I was all for doing the ethical
thing until I found out that it was
going to require that I take days off
from work and I really just cannot
afford that know if it's the ethical
thing it's an absolute demand and you
better fulfill it otherwise you didn't
treat it the ethical right or you know
if you see it as an ethical demand you
don't say well you know I really can't
do it this week could I put it off to
let me check my calendar maybe maybe a
month from now would that be
when I can do my my ethical duty towards
my neighbor towards the world towards my
brother my sister whoever it happens to
be you know no that that is not the
ethical right there the ethical requires
in Hegel's view something at least at
this stage something like absolute
commitment throwing oneself entirely in
there subordinating the other goods and
values that you do in fact hold dear
making sacrifices so he says just as
conversely mere power would be perverted
by essence if it were a one-sided being
for self so you can't have just
power or just essence the ethical has to
comprise both of these and he says on
account of this unity the individuality
is the pure form of substance of
substance which is the content and the
action of the transition from thought to
actuality merely as the movement of an
insubstantial antithesis whose moments
have no particular distinctive content
no essentiality of their own so what
does this lead us to he says the
absolute right of the ethical
consciousness is that the deed the the
doing the action the shape in which it
actualizes itself shall be nothing else
than what it knows and that is a rather
enigmatic thing to end on isn't it
the deed shall be nothing else than what
it knows why because it already knows
what it has to do it's a matter of it
actually a little play on words here
right because we just talk about actual
izing making it an actual 'ti it's a
matter of making it actual of realizing
it of putting it no longer in the realm
of demand and intention but in the realm
of how things are in the process as
we've seen the ethical
self-consciousness is of course going to
be trampling upon the other ethical
self-consciousness but that's not really
discussed in this section but we should
keep that in the back of our minds
you